It's time to play America's favorite game show,
6 Feet From $600.
(background audience applauds)
All right.
Here is how the game show works.
If a player can answer six questions correctly
from six feet away in 60 seconds, they'll win $600.
(background audience applauds)
I know.
And if they answer less than six questions correctly,
they'll go home with a consolation prize
which is a lovely state-of-the-art six pack.
(background audience laughs)
Today, we have three players and three categories.
They are, nom nom nom nom-it's food for thought.
And then we have adorable animals-awwww.
And finally, pop music!
(background audience applauds)
All right, I love these categories.
Okay.
Our first player is Kelly.
Come on out, Kelly.
(background audience applauds)
Hi, Kelly.
Happy to see you.
You're so pretty.
Oh, thank you.
You too. (laughs)
You look so lovely.
Oh, you also.
I love the green.
Oh my gosh.
It's St. Patrick's day.
We have to do that, yeah it's awesome.
If it wasn't COVID, I'd come over and pinch you.
Oh my gosh.
(all laugh)
All right.
Well, you live in New Paltz.
I do, yes.
And you are an analyst.
Is that right?
Personal analyst, yup.
All right, well, what's one secret
that we don't know about you?
I used to work on a cruise ship.
Hey!
Yeah.
That's so fun.
Did you love it?
Oh, it was really fun.
Oh my gosh, yes.
Did you like, was it like, below deck also?
Yes, oh yeah, lots of partying.
(both laugh)
I love it.
Yes.
Kelly, what category of the three are you choosing?
Oh, man.
I think I'll do nom nom nom-it's food for thought. (laughs)
A girl after my (indistinct).
(indistinct) men.
Alright, here we go.
We're going to start the clock at 60 seconds.
Okay, okay.
You ready?
All right, Kelly, here we go.
Yes, yes, yes.
All right, start the clock.
What food is hummus made from?
Chickpeas or potatoes?
Chickpeas.
Yes.
(bell rings)
In the movie E.T. what candy did E.T. enjoy?
Ring Pop or Reese's Pieces?
Reese's Pieces.
Yes.
(bell rings)
How many eggs are in a dozen?
12 or 18?
12.
(bell rings)
Is an avocado a fruit or vegetable?
A fruit.
(bell rings)
In Beyonce's song "Formation", she sings,
"I got blank in my bag."
Is it hot sauce or mayonnaise?
Hot sauce?
It should be.
(bell rings)
You've got 33 seconds.
Which cartoon character was known for eating spinach?
Popeye or Jetson?
Popeye.
(bell rings)
(inaudible background man voice)
(background audience applauds)
Yes.
oh my gosh.
I am so excited. (laughs)
Mike, take it away.
Oh my gosh.
There you go.
Thank you so much.
There's $600 Kelly.
(background audience applauds)
Thank you.
Thank you for playing
and thank you for being so smart and beautiful.
(giggles) Thank you Drew.
Thank you.
Okay let's bring out our next player, Emily.
(background audience applauds)
Hi.
Hi, oh my God.
Dude, I am digging your hair.
Thank you, thank you.
It's new.
It's recent.
Oh I love it.
Thank you, Drew.
It's mutual.
Thank you.
You live in New York City and you're an editor.
I am an editor, yes.
Oh, I know editors.
Yeah, I'm sure.
I love them.
Thank you.
You have, and you're in charge of the narrative.
You can skew things really one way or another
fix or save things.
Yeah, it's like the last step in the line.
Nobody really knows that.
What's one secret about you?
I speak a little bit of Chinese,
but don't ask me to prove it.
You know what I mean?
(background audience laughs)
What's awesome.
Yeah.
You have, do you know like rad, awesome, great.
Anything jubilant in Chinese?
I can say, (speaks foreign language)
which means I speak Chinese but I don't speak it very well.
Oh my gosh.
I love it.
I think you actually do speak it.
Nailed it.
Okay, we have adorable animals and pop music left.
What'd you like to choose?
Pop music, absolutely.
Great.
All right, here we go.
Let's start the clock.
Ready?
Okay.
Alecia Moore is the real name of which artist?
Pink or Madonna?
No idea.
Great.
Pink.
Yes.
(bell rings)
Which year music festival did everyone headline in 2018?
Coachella or South by Southwest?
Coachella.
Yes.
(bell rings)
Which one of these titles is an NSYNC song:
"I want you back" or "I want it that way."
I want it that way.
No.
No?
(buzzer beeps)
In 2010, Lady Gaga wore a dress made out of what
at the VMA's?
Vegetables or meat?
Meat.
Yes.
(bell rings)
Which artist performed at the Super Bowl this year?
The Weekend or Shakira?
The weekend.
Yeah, it is.
(bell rings)
John, Paul, George and Ringo are better known
as what group?
Come on.
The Beatles.
Yes.
(bell rings)
What does MTV stand for?
Music television.
Yes.
(bell rings)
That's it
What?
(bell rings)
Oh my God.
Emily.
Yes.
Mike is going to bring you the art.
Thank you.
And you've won $600.
Happy St. Patrick's Day.
(background crowd applauds)
Thank you, it's time for our last player.
Please welcome, Marquesa.
(background crowd applauds)
Hi Marquesa.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so happy to see you.
I'm so happy to see you too.
Marquesa, you're from New York City
and you're a technology engagement speaker.
I am.
But can you tell us one secret about yourself?
Let's see, one secret about myself
is I moved to New York City with a dream,
almost 30 years ago, and I'm living my dream.
So it's true what they say.
You can have your dream New York City.
And my dream is I help people look fabulous on Zoom.
(Marquesa laughs)
Well, maybe you can do a segment on the show
for us to teach people some tips.
I would love to.
All right.
We're down to adorable animals.
You ready?
I'm ready.
I love every single animal I see.
You and my daughter Marquesa.
Okay.
Ready?
Start the clock.
What is the smallest breed of dog?
Chihuahua or Golden Retriever?
Chihuahua.
(bell rings)
What is the popular children's show, Barney?
What kind of animal was Barney?
Barney?
He was a dog, he was a dog.
No.
A cat.
Dinosaur.
Which color is an arctic fox?
White or purple?
Purple.
No, white.
(bell rings)
Okay.
When does a baby giraffe starts to walk?
Within an hour of being born, or is it 9 months?
It's in an hour.
Yes.
(bell rings)
What is the biggest animal on planet?
African elephant or the blue whale?
Whale.
Yes.
(bell rings)
Garfield the cat hates one certain day of the week.
Which is it?
Mondays or Thursdays?
Mondays.
Yes.
(bell rings)
Garfield hates Mondays.
I love Mondays.
Are humans considered to be amphibians or mammals?
What?
I know, mammals apparently.
Cats are said to have how many lives?
Cats, 9 lives.
Yes, I have a cat.
(bell rings)
(background crowd applauds)
Marquesa.
By the way, I totally was like,
oh no, I don't know they're amphibians or mammals.
So we were both like, there you go.
Thank you Mike.
Oh my goodness.
Yes, okay, let me just bend down.
Oh, Marquesa, I'm so happy that you won $600
on St. Patrick's Day.
All right, thank you everybody for playing.
That's all we have today for 6 Feet From $600.
(upbeat music)